يقوم محمد البالغ من العمر 8 سنوات بأعماله اليومية في
جلب الماء، وجمع قصاصات
من الورق والبلاستيك لإشعال النار
لمساعدة والدته في طهي وجبتهم اليومية،
لكنه يفضل أن يكون
[موسيقى] في
مكان آخر حيث يأتي الطنين من
الطائرات الإسرائيلية بدون طيار التي تحوم فوق رؤوسهم.
لا تذهب بعيدًا أبدًا
أكثر من أي شيء آخر، الأطفال هنا
يفقدون الشعور
بالأمان بين عشية وضحاها. قصفت الطائرات الحربية الإسرائيلية
مسجد يافا في دير بيلا، لم
يكن هناك أحد ولكن الجميع سمع
ذلك في المخيم، أفضل ما يمكن للوالدين
فعله هو إبقاء الأطفال بعيدًا عنهم.
خطر ولكن لا يوجد هروب لقد
رأوا هؤلاء الأطفال الكثير بالفعل
نحن نفتقد مدينتنا لقد عشنا بشكل جيد يقول
جواه الآن كل ما نراه هو جثث في
كل مكان لا توجد خدمات أساسية
هنا القمامة تتراكم في
الشارع يقول محمد نذهب من واحد
مكان إلى آخر ويواصلون
قصفنا ومع ذلك ما زالوا
يلعبون كطائرات بدون طيار تحلق
فوقنا